Bonjour, ici Jackie Chan.
Bim bim !
Boooow.
Les amis, je ne me lasse pas
de découvrir à quel point les gens peuvent rechercher des trucs
bizarres sur Google.
Et je sais, que ça vous arrive aussi,
et que ça m'arrive aussi.
L'historique, je pense bien évidemment à l'effacer
avant chaque vidéo.
Mais vous ? Qu'en est-il de vous ?
Si là maintenant, je vais de ton historique, il se passe quoi ?
Et bah t'es mal... t'es très mal.
Aujourd'hui, on est sur un jeu qui s'appelle
idiots.win, ne le prennez pas mal contre vous.
Il y a le début d'une recherche Google,
et on doit trouver laquelle est la plus tapée
avec mon skill
d'homme qui traduit bien évidemment...
euh... très très mal.
Par exemple, pourquoi les blancs hum hum..
Pourquoi les tigres blancs sont blancs  ?
Voilà, quand je vous parlais de recherches étranges, je parlais par exemple de ça.
Pourquoi les rhinocéros blancs sont en voie de disparition.
Pourquoi les tigres blancs sont en voie de disparition.
Pourquoi les briquets blancs n'ont pas de chance ?
WTF?
Bon mec, pourquoi les tigres blancs sont blancs ?
C'est ça qu'on veut savoir...
Et nan c'est pas ça !
Pourquoi les rhinocéros blancs sont en voie de disparition ?
Et nan !
Mais bien sûr où avais-je la tête ?
Pourquoi les globules blancs sont faibles ?
Non bah non...
Mais bien sûr, pourquoi les tigres sont en voie de disparition.
Bon, et bah voilà on a tout perdu !
Niquel, alors...
Est-ce qu'un *mmmhmmhmm*...
Est-ce qu'Angela Jolie est malade ?
Ouais c'est ça.
Et bah non putain.
J'ai fais le mec à pas regarder les autres, ça m'apprendra.
Est-ce que quelqu'un est là ?
*rires*
Oh non putain ça aurait été trop beau.
Les gens qui connaissent pas internet
Ah on se moque des vieux, on est des petits cons
Tu sais, le mec qui connaît pas Internet et qui pense que derrière Google il y a vraiment un gars qui répond à tout le monde.
Est-ce que quelqu'un est là ?
is anyone up, j'sais pas ce que ça veut dire.
is anyone up?
Est-ce quelqu'un qui monte. Pourquoi les gens cherchent ça sur Google ?
Car ils cherchent un gars pour faire des montages.
Ah peut-être, peut-être, on a une théorie.
Pourquoi je suis si...
faché ?
fatigué ?
bavard ?
ou assoifé ?
Moi, je dirais, fatigué.
Bah bien sûr !
La réponse est, tu travailles trop, bien entendu.
Alors, my mind is be...
*rires*
Ça, c'est les recherches Google de Van Damme.
my mind.
Mon esprit *mmhmmhm*...
Mon esprit devient terne,
un peu glauque.
Mon esprit me joue des tours.
Mon esprit est mieux que celui des autres.
Mon esprit est beau.
Mon esprit est manipulé.
Attention, hein.
Ça, c'est les tops recherches Google d'un asile psychiatrique en fait.
Ça fout un peu le bad, ouais, ouais !
Mon esprit me joue des tours.
Ah nan. Mon esprit est contrôlé ?
Oh, c'est glauque...
Can we have, pouvons-nous...
avoir des rapports sexuels ?
en espagnol ?
C'est la seule phrase que je sais dire.
Vous avez remarqué ou pas ? Parce que j'habitais à Antony
et du coup, dès que je prenais le RER
pour rentrer chez moi.
Et bah j'entendais
et elle est restée dans la tête.
Merci les touristes !
Pouvons-nous... avoir notre balle ?
ou alors pouvez-vous nous rendre notre Obama ?
*rires*
C'est pas mal ça
Bon, can we have sex, genre le mec désespéré.
Oh non, oh non, c'est triste.
Alors, comment puis-je éviter...
le vol d'identité ?
le diabète ?
d'avoir la grippe ?
payer les taxes ?
Oh, le fisc tombe sur son historique, le mec est foutu.
la taxe sur le patrimoine ?
On part sur un délire de fraudes fiscales là quand même..
Moi je dirais le truc des taxes.
Et voilà !
Putain, vous avez pas honte ?
Comment vos routes et vos écoles sont construites à votre avis ?
Comment le trottoir sur lequel tu marches est-il construit à ton avis ?
Comment l'arrêt de bus que tu casses pour exprimer ton mécontentement est-il payé à ton avis ?
*clap*
Impôts ! La vidéo est sponsorisée par le gouvernement, bien sûr.
Est-ce que les humains peuvent...
Alors, là, on va perdre foi en l'humanité.
peuvent vivre sur Mars ?
Ah pas mal ! Quand tu es plus qu'un exilé fiscal, tu es un exilé de la planète.
Mais je vous rassure, sur Mars
le gouvernement mettra un système d'impôts et de taxes.
*rires*
Vous pourrez pas aller là-bas pour éviter les impôts.
Est-ce que les humains..
peuvent manger des glands ?
Est-ce que les humains...
peuvent avoir la rage ?
Oui, c'est pour ça que Pasteur a inventé le vaccin contre la rage, voilà.
Oui, j'étends ma culture, on apprends ça au collège.
Est-ce que les humains...
peuvent avoir des puces ?
Moi je pense c'est vivre sur Mars.
Nan, même pas ?
Ah, les gens veulent savoir si on peut avoir des puces ?
Mais nan, mais nan...
Genre, mais nan.
*rires*
Et c'est vrai ça, on connait les poux et les lentes, mais les puces ?
Est-ce qu'on peut avoir des puces ?
Il y a plus de deux milles espèces de puces.
Aaaaah. Et mec.
*étonnement*
Il s'est inspiré de ça, le mec qui a fait Helion,
le bébé Helion.
Celui-là là.
Merde.
C'lui-là, pardon.
C'est totalement une puce géante, en fait.
Bon bah après quelques recherches et une photo de chats mignons.
Oui, on peut avoir des puces.
C'était l'instant culture.
*bruit de trompette*
Ça n'a rien d'une trompette mais bon.
Est-il toxique de...
manger des pommes de terres crues ?
manger une banane et un œuf en même temps
manger un œuf et une banane
manger des graines de pommes
Pour les enfants qui ont peur qu'un pommier pousse dans leur corps. Quand j'étais petit, je pensais ça, ouais.
de manger un œuf et une banane sucrée ?
Bon clairement, y'a un délire avec l’œuf et la banane, y'a un truc qui va pas.
On va dire banana and egg together.
Non ? Juste un œuf et une banane ?
Nan ? Des patates crues ?
Nan ? Des grains de pommes ?
Oui ! Mon dieux !
"Du cyanure, les pépins de pommes ont un fort goût amer, vous savez la plupart des mauvais goûts dans la nature servent à nous mettre en garde contre une substance dangereuse."
En effet, le pépin de pomme est riche en cyanure.
Nan ? "Le cyanure : un poison puissant" Mais hmmm, j'savais pas.
"1 mg de cyanure par masse corporelle suffit à vous envoyer dans l'autre monde."
"Heureusement, même si cela paraît très peu, il vous faudrait manger 143 pépins de pommes pour atteindre cette dose, soit 19 pommes d'un coup."
Attends mec, est-ce qu'on serait en train d'apprendre
qu'il est possible de suicider en manger des pépins de pommes ?
Got damn it!
On apprends des choses avec ces conneries de recherches Google là.
*rires*
Est-ce qu'un tatouage est...
Ah, ça m'intéresse !
(Est-ce qu'un tatouage est...)
censé te faire un bleu ? Une contusion.
Oui, on t'a quand même explosé la peau, troué la peau.
(Est-ce qu'un tatouage est...)
supposé peler ?
Bah j'espère bien car moi, il a pelé mon gars mais plus qu'un joueur de foot !
*cris aigu*
*bruit d'une voiture (qui est presque décédé)*
*rires*
Cette pauvre voiture, comment je la tue à chaque vidéo.
Est-ce qu'un tatouage est...
un péché ?
Est-ce qu'un tatouage...
vaut le coup ?
Est-ce qu'un tatouage est...
supposé avoir la fade après cicatrisation
Ah j'hésite entre les gens qui ont une religion et
qui voulait savoir si un tatouage c'était péché.
Ou alors, les gens qui ont fait un tatouage et qui ont des symptômes chelous
et qui veulent s'assurer que tu vas bien.
Moi j'dirais pelé.
Merde.
Euh, un péché alors ?
Bah ouais c'est un péché.
C'est ça. Ah j'avoue, vu que je suis athée, je m'étais jamais posé la question.
Mais franchement, j'avoue que quand tu as une religion, tu dois te demander...
En plus c'est un truc nouveau le tatouage j'veux dire.
Au moment où les textes ont été écrits y'avait p't'être pas de tatouages.
Est-ce que je dis une connerie ? Peut-être.
"Le premier tatouage se situe en Égypte avec une
momie de 2200 av. J.-C."
Au revoir Lucas.
Bon c'est sûr, ça c'était pas autant démocratisé comme maintenant.
Tin, on apprends plein dans de choses dans cette vidéo.
C'est fou. À la base
on voulait pas apprendre des choses mais...
Qu'est-ce que les filles font... mhmhmm...
*rires*
C'est bon ça !
Qu'est-ce que les filles font...
aux sleepovers ?
Sleepover, c'est passer une nuit
loin de chez soi ou alors chez soi
avec un ou deux invités.
Qu'est-ce que les filles font...
dans leur lit
Qu'est-ce que les filles...
aiment
De quoi les filles...
aimer parler
Qu'est-ce que les filles...
veulent
*rires*
Il est à bout de souffle lui !
Je ne comprends rien à ce système !
Qu'est-ce qu'elles veulent !
De quoi elles aiment parler, je dirais.
Ah merde !
Qu'est-ce qu'elles aiment ?
Et c'est ça !
Bah les gars, globalement, elles aiment les mêmes trucs que nous !
Elles aiment autant le jeu vidéo, que le cinéma,
que euh..., le jeu vidéo.
*rires*
Est-ce que la Grande Bretagne...
est une monarchie
(Est-ce que la Grande Bretagne...)
est en Angleterre ?
est au Royaume-Uni ?
(Est-ce que la Grande Bretagne...)
fait parti du Royaume-Uni ?
fait parti, de l'Europe ?
Et ce qui m'aide pas, est-ce que la Grande Bretagne. est en Angleterre nan ?
Ouais bah voilà.
Alors cette amalgame il est ouf, je pensais que
la Grande Bretagne c'est la même chose que le Royaume-Uni
et en fait il y a une mini...  enfin, une grosse différence quand même,
c'est que la Grande Bretagne, c'est une île !
Composé par l'Angleterre, l'Écosse et le Pays de Galles.
Et le Royaume-Uni. c'est un état composé par les mêmes pays.
Plus (+) l'Irlande du Nord, pardon.
Donc la Grande Bretagne, c'est une zone géographique
et le Royaume-Uni., c'est un état !
Putain, j'savais pas !
Comment je pouvais ne pas savoir ça ?
Bah j'ai jamais aimé la géo. en même temps.
Oh la vielle excuse,
Le mec est bien claqué du cul. Et attention
c'est l'heure de la dernière, on donne tout ce qu'on a.
Aidez-moi, je mmhmhm...
*rires*
Ça va être terrible !
Aidez-moi...
je m'ennuie
j'ai accidentellement mhmhm
Aidez-moi...
je suis en vie
WTF?
Besoin d'aide...
en espagnol
en langage des signes
Ooh
Je pense que c'est "J'ai accidentellement..."
Nan !
"Aidez-moi je m'ennuie" ?
Nan.
"Aidez-moi je suis en vie", nan c'est pas ça
Aidez-moi...
...en espagnol ?
*rires*
Allez! Les LV2 que personne ne respecte !
Et bien voilà, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo.
Moi, je pense que les trucs Google, on va arrêter avant un moment.
Le mec, il se suce la bite dans une première vidéo où il cherche ce que les gens cherchent sur lui sur Google
puis dans une seconde vidéo, il cherche ce que les gens cherchent quand ils ne cherchent pas lui sur Google
J'l'avais préparé cette phrase.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu.
Et continuez de faire comme ça, des recherches Google tous les jours
Toutes plus improbables les unes que les autres, car je trouve ça très très drôle.
J'espère que vous tomberez jamais sur les miennes hein.
*rires*
Et à bientôt
*outro*